[Musique]
et
tous y est
toujours eu une relation particulière
avec toronto
mais en juillet 2003 ils interrompent
leur tournée européenne pour se rendre
au canada et donner un des plus grands
concerts de leur carrière conceptualisé
par le célèbre producteur torontois
michael cole est financé en partie par
les gouvernements de l'époque
le concert devait redorer l'image de la
ville reine qui avait été placée sur la
liste noire de l'om s lors de la
pandémie du strass
c'était plus le woodstock que natty
c'était le plus beau c'est vainement
musquin que je mets du jeu etc
près de cinq cent mille spectateurs
répondent à l'appel et assistent à 11
heures de musique par quinze artistes
d'envergure dont la majorité sont
canadiens et au souvenir de tous
l'événement monstre s'était déroulé sans
anicroche
tout le monde était vraiment y avait pas
de bien vous aucune violence
[Musique]
nous sommes
montre les rushes et ici d'ici présents
sur scène cette journée là quelques
artistes francophones on avait 15
minutes à jouer et s'adapter mais on a
joué on était tellement énervée
tellement d'erreurs que on a terminé
après je pense que c'était neuf ou dix
minutes on a joué on a joué si
rapidement
il y avait au moins 50 j'ai au moins 50
60 mille québécois qui était le puits
fait ses choux alors qu'en étant qu'il
ya eu une réaction qui avait pas
nécessairement parce que plusieurs
groupes qui pensaient puis lequel il y
avait un goût francophone alors c'est là
qu'il avait embarqué à la fin de la
soirée la foule est comblé par
l'événement organisé en moins de deux
mois
les écrans géants
on ne reverra pas d'événement de cette
envergure de sitôt mais le retour à la
scène ronge certains artistes qui
aimerait pouvoir faire leur part en
temps de pandémie
c'est ce que certains venaient l'idée
qu'un en étant bien ancrée je me suis
dit qu'est ce qu'on fait sur immunité
pour une cause le faire en attendant le
30 juillet 2003 reste gravé dans la
mémoire de milliers de canadiens ici
comme un côté palette radio-canada à
hamilton